[Music]
[Applause]
wherever they have a sense that there is
money in whichever industry that is
legal or illegal they're going to try to
bank on it at some point drugs were the
most profitable Revenue right cuz they
were illegal hard to get cars and there
was a huge demand in the US they're
still making money out of out of drugs
but the thing is that's sort of like a
established Revenue stream now right
they managed to have that streamline of
Revenue established no issue no problem
they can even sort of like calculate how
much money they're going to make over a
year of shipping different kinds of
drugs and stuff so that's basically
settled for them for their business
there was a time like maybe 10 years ago
when there were still drug organizations
that they would get money from a
politician to let them alone and let
them work and you know like Transit
drugs through their city or stuff like
that so they pay the politicians they
used to pay politicians they used to you
know like bribe politicians basically so
like okay I'm going to so that was not
an income that was an outcome you know
that was like okay I'm losing money to
pay politicians still allow me to keep
making money now it's the other way
around now they have control the whole
country and now they're saying like we
had elections if you're not stepping out
I'm going to leave you out of the
equation by killing you and setting up
my own people so now they're setting up
their own people their own Majors their
own Governors their own chief of police
so they don't have to pay them anymore
so they're like okay you don't like it
I'm going to kill you now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to set you up as a
governor of this state and we're going
to do business both of us you're going
to give me all contracts for
construction for road work for building
government buildings all the contracts
well Imports exports all of the
government contracts are going to give
them to me I'm going to handle that and
that's making them tons of money they
were not still that powerful back then
there were still like cartels I don't
even call them cartels anymore they're
either criminal enter prices or sell the
paramilitary armies you know everything
but Dr cels I think that's a term that
it's absolutely outdated we we shouldn't
be calling them dra cartels cuz they're
not dra
cartels Mexican cartels have officially
gone Legit The Fortunes of cartels may
have started by doing illegal stuff but
now they're taking over the country's
legitimate Industries too and nothing is
off the table us is saying Mexico owes
us like 5 years of water they haven't
paid and Mexico is like we are on a
draft we don't have enough water to pay
you back and we need that water for our
locals cartels learned about this they
say like so water is money now so want
to control every river Creek Lake at
least in the region we own the lines are
getting so blurred that's getting really
hard to tell the difference between the
Mexican cartel and the Mexican
governments they're becoming one and the
same but none of us should be surprised
because the exact same thing happened
not too long ago right here in the good
old us of a it's January 17 1920 in
America prohibition had just has gone
into effect alcohol is officially
illegal and the people are losing their
minds they need their liquor no matter
how much it costs so guess what the only
people that were willing to meet this
demand were the ones who were willing to
break the law and just like that a super
profitable black market for Bootleggers
emerged Bootleggers made a multi-million
dollar Fortune selling people the one
thing they wanted the most but once
prohibition was over they couldn't just
go back to their regular lives of
suckers so they Ed that alcohol money to
expand into other rackets protection
rackets prostitution brought those drug
trafficking you name it they use their
alcohol money to get into it and thus
the American Mafia as we know it today
was born eventually five families the
most powerful Italian mafia families in
America would emerge and as they grew
they would come to infiltrate almost
every aspect of American society
Trucking labor unions all the way to
American politics and once they have
more money than they knew what to do
with they would start to work their way
into legitimate businesses it got so bad
that the average person wouldn't be able
to tell if a business was legit or Mafia
run eventually the American government
was able to crack down on them but other
countries aren't so lucky in Japan the
Yakuza Rose to power because gambling
was illegal so they provided illegal
gambling services and then they took
that gambling money and got into every
other racket you can imagine and once
they had more money than they knew what
to do with they would also Venture into
the world of legitimate businesses as
well they got into real estate the stock
market startup Investments and working
with International companies the Yakuza
basically became a giant quasi hedge
fund with a $100 billion in their pocket
how do you beat that the answer is you
don't these days the Yakuza is so deeply
embedded in Japanese society that you
can't really even distinguish between a
Yakuza member and a businessman because
many times they are one and the same and
all of this was because of one thing
prohibition see whenever you make
something illegal you empower the most
vicious men of society and if you
prohibit something long enough this will
always be the end outcome and now it's
Mexico's turn but unlike Japan and
America Mexico isn't some rich country
with a thriving economy that can at
least balance out this organized crime
no the cartels have already started
controlling all of Mexico's most
valuable resources food natural
resources Transportation companies and
even the water supply is under their
influence while millions of everyday
Mexicans are first to work directly or
indirectly for the cartel in some
capacity that Mexico that the cartels
are the fifth largest employers in
Mexico right below the Mexican
Government so I guess Mexico needs to
find a way to legitimize all that dirty
money all that you know money made with
dirty hands put it into a legal
basically laer money for these guys and
then stop their revenue and and opening
up more I don't know man shops or
whatever and now they're coming from the
Mexican Government too and at this point
there may be nothing anyone can do to
stop them they went from small
organization to get earning social bases
to getting funding to trying to
destabilize government to trying to
delegitimize government trying to step
in and now teaching official tactics to
their people you know back then was like
just get off AK and let's start shooting
now they have uniforms military uniforms
withis here CJ and G stay dangerous
subscribe for more and say hello to the
failed state of
[Music]
Mexico these cartels have a lot of money
and if you want more money one of the
easiest ways to save an extra $300 a
year right now is to cancel pay
subscriptions that you don't use anymore
this is because the average person is
going to waste $300 on unused
subscriptions this year which is why why
I use today sponsor rocket money rocket
money is an all-in-one Finance platform
that helps you save more and spend less
this personal finance app allows you to
manage subscriptions lower bills build a
custom budget and grow your savings all
in one place for me I love using rocket
money to view all my subscriptions all
in one place and to cancel the ones I
don't use anymore another favorite
feature of mine is that you can connect
your bills or upload receipts of your
bills and their negotiators will work to
lower your bills for you you just pay
them a portion of whatever they save you
this means you can reduce your cell
phone bill bills cable bills or even
lower your car insurance without lifting
a finger plus rocket money helps you
track your net worth so to save more and
spend less join over 5 million members
using rocket money today go to Rocket
money.com Jak or click the link below to
get started for free you can also unlock
even more features with premium that's
rocket money.com to get started for
free in the 1980s and90s the US
government was cracking down hard on the
Italian mafia at the same time the
Colombian carel were starting to
disintegrate thanks to America taking
out their Caribbean smuggling networks
and now that all the main sources of
these illegal products were disappearing
smuggling them into the us became a
major Black Market business opportunity
and one new Criminal organization just
couldn't wait to take advantage of it
the Mexican cartels unlike the
Colombians the Mexican cartels didn't
have to worry about Crossing an ocean to
get their product into America all they
had to do was slip it past a simple land
border easy and with their main
competitors gone the Mexican cartels
quickly took over the movement of
illegal products into America and since
the this wasn't just one Big Cartel but
a bunch of smaller ones who regularly
fought against each other even though
smuggling made them Rich they also had
to deal with a lot of violence and
bloodshed the caloa cartel the warus
cartel were by far two of the biggest
and they were making bank flooding
American markets with every kind of
elicit substance you could think of but
eventually these big Mexican cartels
just had too much money and I mean come
on personal fantas 101 if they let the
cash sit there it's just going to lose
value so they started looking for
legitimate Investments to pour all their
cash into cartel's got to invest too and
what would their target Mexico's avocado
industry for years Mexico have been
supplying American Millennials with the
key ingredient for their avocado toast
and guacamole and now the cartel wanted
a piece of the action avocados are green
gold so first they went to avocado
farmers and threatened to kill them in
their families if they didn't start
paying the cartels a protection fee and
when that wasn't enough they just took
control of the Farms altogether and
became the suppliers
themselves a favorite food for Canadians
has become a cash crop for merciless
Mexican cartels everything that produces
money they're going to be interested in
unleashing a reign of terror on any who
oppos them regular people are the one
that suffer the violence you are a very
powerful
organization these guy just understand
blood but avocados are just one of the
Mexican cartel's many legitimized
businesses they also invested in the
mining industry the cartels offer these
valuable mining operations protection in
exchange for a piece of the pie and by
protecting they me you and your loved
ones get to live another day that really
boosted their revenue then they move
from that to other revenue streams one
of them being uh mining first they
started embedding with M International
mining companies to bring Security even
if those mining companies I reached out
to they say they have no clue they don't
do that kind of like deals with cartels
and they disguise everything as going
with private security companies well
guess what private security companies
they they are right they are Curel but
even that didn't feel like enough merely
taking a cut of a business's profits was
just too shortsighted for a cartel like
theirs they didn't just want a measly
protection racket they wanted to own the
mining industry to own the avocado Farms
so the cartel basically owns the
security around most of these mining
companies on different natural resources
right that was first the beginning then
cartel start and saying like oh you know
what it looks like we have rumors that
here could be
a lot of new silver unexploded yet why
don't we establish right there and and
hold that place for a while so when if
mining company comes and say like hey
want to explode that place we're already
here man yeah you're going to have to
you know give us the good money to keep
you safe to get rid of all these people
and and we're good and and that's been
that's been going on and on in different
places which brings us to today Mexican
cartels are everywhere and they're not
just killing people over funny vitment
and flower anymore instead they're
murdering regular civilians for stuff
like avocados and natural resources when
we see cartels fighting like in places
like zakas Pua all that stuff the
government tells us oh they're fighting
a drug route it's like dude that is that
is not even a drug route there is no
Port there is no main Highway that leads
to the US whatever not the only one
that's not a production site but what
you have is a lot of silver like in
zakas so these guys want to own that
place cuz they know there's going to be
a new prodct coming in town and that's
big money for them big money when Mexico
was going through a drought a few years
back the value of water shot up over
nights and within days the cartel
pounced on the opportunity and turn its
focus from Big Crown to big water almost
immediately I I was there during uh
during a draft right one of the worst
that ever hid northern Mexico water was
absolutely scars the government was
telling us you know you need to take uh
control of the water usage cuz we're out
of water cartels learned about this [__]
they say like oh so water is cars now so
water is money now so we want to control
every river Creek Lake in this region at
least in the region we own and they
start doing that in in in Chihuahua one
Anonymous cartel operative told Vice
that quote water is now a valuable asset
for us and as it becomes more scarce the
more we will fight to make sure we have
enough End quotes there is a huge lake
called uh Lago Aro beautiful Lake in in
the middle of the of the mountains of
the hills in Chihuahua the last time I
was there dude I mean it was probably
only full to the third part of it
absolutely empty and when I asked locals
that no one want to want to say what
exactly was happening to the Adu River
and they showed me how the cartels by
night goes with uh every night go to
that Creek to that to that lake with
these water pipes and start extracting a
lot of water from from it and then they
sell that water to hotels stores
airbnbs for tourists you go to a hotel
in the middle of a draft of a draft and
and and and you can open the the faucet
and leave it open for hours and you're
not going to run out of water but if you
are in a local house you're immediately
going to be out of water like probably
within an hour of leaving the faucet
open and all these guys are sourcing
from the cartel and the cartels are
making tons of money so they are now
controlling is this they're controlling
the Water Supplies water suppli and it
makes sense water is the ultimate
commodity if it's scarce then you can
raise the price as much as you want
without ever losing customers but water
was just the beginning and they've
already taken over so much of Mexico the
high- raking cartel members are now
close to
[Music]
Untouchable October 17 2019 it was just
another normal Thursday in kakon Mexico
when out of nowhere where the police
busted into the home of a man named oido
Guzman Lopez and arrested him for
trafficking drugs into the us but this
wasn't just any ordinary drug dealer
though oidio Guzman is the youngest son
of El Chapo he's one of the three
leaders of the what we call Los chapitos
which is the main faction of the celo
cartel a video helped take over the
family business after El Chapo was
extradited to the US in 2017 and he had
a literal Army behind him ready to kill
indiscriminately until he was released
hundreds of cartel gunman overpowered
the police almost immediately when they
heard their leader have been arrested
they set up roadblocks they open fire
with automatic weapons on the city with
no regard for how many innocent lives
they were taking he was arrested in 2019
in kakan and Pa Hell broke lose in kakan
or what we call kak kanaso hundreds and
hundreds of henchmen went out the city
started fighting the government they
grabbed the families of the military
members involved there is a military
base in kakan they grabbed the families
locked them up on their houses on the
military base and and set a lot of
explosives around and they threatened
the government say if you don't release
a video we're going to kill all these
families they opened a hall on the
prison on the main State Prison in kakan
to let a lot of a lot of loer members in
jail out armed all the and asked him
just shoot our city everywhere and
everyone so imagine a city of less than
probably less than 300,000 people
absolutely taken by probably 100,000 you
know arm people around Ido wasn't in
custody for more than a few hours before
the Mexican government was forced to
cave in and release him they were
desperately begging the cartel to stop
killing people there is an estimation of
the caloa cartel that there's like
100,000 members that's a army because
the cartella has so much power they're
like you know what not only are we
taking over this entire town if you're
in the military that was part of this
operation we're going after your family
I think like 29 people were killed they
took hostages they were burning down
like army barracks and stuff in the area
and the president of Mexico he said
surely the capture of one drug Smuggler
could not be more valuable than the
lives of innocent civilians it was it
was a mess so the Mexican Government had
to release obido from their from their
custody and that that was embarrassing
for the government of course and that
was empowering for the for the caloa
cartel so the message was clear the
government doesn't own Mexico the cartel
does imagine how weak and corrupt the
Mexican Government had to be that it
couldn't even make a rest without
inciting an allout war and if you think
that sounds bad just wait because it
gets much much worse soon the cartel
won't even have to shoot up an entire
city to force the government's hand
because just like they moved into the
world of business the biggest Mexican
cartels basically are the government
now this is Abel Moretta Abel was a
Mexican lawyer and politician for the
citizens movement political party in
2021 he was running for mayor in a small
town called K but unlike his opponents
Abel was very vocal when it came to
speaking up against the cartels as part
of his campaign he promised the
residents of kame and Mexico as a whole
that if he was elected he would fight
fearlessly against the cartel's reign of
terror in a video he posted on Twitter
he said even with the bad guys being
owners of the streets I am a man of the
law I am going to impose order my hand
is firm I am not scared I think you can
guess what happened next just one day
after speaking out against the tells
abble was out in the streets hanging out
flyers in broad daylight when he was
approached by two men who pulled out
guns and shot him at least 10 times to
most people it wasn't any surprise but
Abel wasn't the only Mexican politician
with a Target on his back over 150
different political candidates were
murdered during the most recent election
season in Mexico Yes you heard me right
150 now they have control the whole
country and now they're they're saying
like we had elections two years ago and
we had over
150 candidates killed during elections
150 politicians killed in a single
election period wow that was only
because cartels wanted to set up their
own people and that was a show of force
like if you're not stepping out I'm
going to I'm going to leave you out of
the equation by killing you and setting
up my own people and now the cartel
wants to actively take those government
positions for itself they don't want to
deal with paying off politicians anymore
they don't want to deal with murdering
politicians no the cartels want to be
the politicians themselves because if
they're the ones in charge if they're
the ones making the laws and controlling
the police why all their problems would
go away but if they have to murder every
single Mexican politician in the process
they clearly will now they're setting up
their own people their own Majors their
own Governors their own chief of police
so they don't have to pay them anymore
so they're like okay you don't like it
I'm going to you now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to set you up as a
governor of this state and we're going
to do business both of us you're you're
going to give me all contracts for
construction for road work for building
um government buildings all the
contracts of imports exports all of the
government contracts you're going to
give them to me I'm going to handle that
and that's making them tons of money cuz
they're getting all government contracts
I don't know man I don't know but it's
getting out of
[Music]
hand
unlike the mafia and the Yakuza who both
have working relationships with the
government officials in their countries
and who knew how to hold back the
Mexican cartels have none of that mercy
so as of right now it looks like the
cartel is destined to take over Mexico
and there's literally to nothing we can
do to stop them do you think it's
reversible I don't think it's reversible
to be honest I will I would love to say
yes but there's no how how will you make
this backwards you know how how do you
deescalate the power of these people and
not only violent power the corruption
power the power they have in politics
they the power they have in into e
economics you know Mexican economy has a
lot to do with cartels they become
completely ingrained into Mexico's
everyday life and economy they're
indistinguishable for major businesses
in the country and now they're close to
getting near total control of the
government itself this is so
sophisticated yeah they're becoming very
very very very sophisticated it's
fascinating I don't know how this ends I
think How It Ends off the top of my head
is I think one cartel would have to
dominate the entire country and when
that happens maybe maybe there will be
maybe it will become more peaceful I
don't know you know because there won't
be so many so much fighting in between
the different cartels and and it's one
unit running the entire operation I
don't I don't see any other way I don't
see it reversing it's not reversing I
mean this is not a draug cartell
operations now this is we're talking
about a hybrid insurgent
criminal movement so Solutions on one
hand you could legalize drugs in America
but that would take the government
actually creating treatment centers and
stuff or else the entire country would
end up like Portland Oregon who legalize
everything and let's be real we know the
government is probably not capable of
pulling that off on the other hand the
US can declare yet another endless war
against the cartels that probably won't
do anything but waste money and cost
lives so whether you like it or not
Mexico is de facto in the hands of the
cartels now and who knows what they're
planning with their new found power
next and you want to know what else is a
State America at least when it comes to
the justice system especially when it
comes to everyone's favorite Private
Island owner FY jste and we expose it
all in our new documentary on our new
crime Channel how to get away with it
the Epstein case has been dirty from the
very beginning in this new documentary
we interviewed the journalist who was
the one that published jep's Infamous
black book that contained all of jep's
rich and Powerful contacts journalist
Nick Bryant and he provided a wealth of
neverbe heard details on the case
there's been four presidential ad
administ ations that have covered up uh
the Jeffrey Epson
case the Bush Administration has covered
it up the Obama Administration has
covered it up the Trump Administration
has covered it up and now Biden is
covering it up and the cover up is
pretty Immaculate in the United States
there are are 535 legislators um there
are
435 in the House of Representatives and
and then there's 100 senators and not
one of the federal legislators has asked
for an investigation in Jeffrey abstein
so when you cover up a crime you are
aiding embedding that crime so the
American government is aiding embedding
child trafficking he goes over the
Staggering of mouth evidence that shows
JY was working for the CIA and I keep
saying it but this is one of my favorite
videos we've made as of late and it's an
incredibly important one too so click
the card on the screen to watch now and
don't forget to subscribe click the card
on the screen to watch
now